prince harry has a new gig
the duke of sussex will now be the chief
impact officer at
betterup a silicon valley startup that
focuses on
coaching and mental health the sussex is
i think feel very far away from us
over here in the uk they're they're in
la they're putting
they're putting their time and energy
into really important courses
the company started in 2013 and its
mission
is to unlock greater potential purpose
and passion by bringing together
coaching ai technology
and behavioral science in an article on
the company's website
harry explains why he decided to join
the team and how his life experiences
have shaped him
including the decade he spent serving in
the military it's a new challenge
it's a new chapter right harry also
shares that he personally works with a
better up coach
who has given him sound advice and a
fresh perspective
quote i firmly believe that focusing on
and prioritizing our mental fitness
unlocks potential and opportunity that
we never knew we had inside of us
what i've learned in my own life is the
power of transforming
pain into purpose harry says that as the
first
chief impact officer his goal is to lift
up critical dialogues around
mental health build supportive and
compassionate communities
and foster an environment for honest and
vulnerable conversations
quote my hope is to help people develop
their inner strength
resilience and confidence sir can i ask
what did you think of the interview
of course this all comes just two weeks
after harry and megan's tell-all
interview with oprah winfrey
my understanding is that um prince
charles did want to
issue a more detailed statement in
response to the oprah interview
and possibly address some of those
issues point by point
um but there was a an evening to think
about things and in the end it was
it was decided that a shorter statement
would be better that actually by going
into things point by point could be
could be potentially more more damaging
and and give more ammunition for this
row to continue
following the interview with oprah
buckingham palace released a short
statement which did not give any detail
on the royals reaction
to some of the more shocking claims made
by the duke and duchess
which included harry alleging that his
dad prince charles
cut him and his family off financially
after he and megan stepped down as
senior members of the royal family in
march
2020. i think prince charles and prince
william um
were keen to correct perhaps some of the
things that the couple had said i know
that prince charles was particularly
frustrated by the suggestion that
financially
charles just cut the couple off when if
you speak to sources in charleston's
camp
and that wasn't the case he did continue
funding them for quite some time
after they moved first to canada and
then to america
so yes i think there was at one point
um a feeling that they wanted to address
more than just the
issue of race which of course the queen
said in that statement was
was a serious issue but it was decided
that a shorter more succinct statement
would be better to issue publicly
and those other matters could be dealt
with privately as a family
[Music]